so the gun control activist promoted by
julia reed pulls a gun out and starts
shooting at people
turns out the people who are accusing
you of violence are actually committing
quite a bit of violence in this country
have you noticed a few months ago a
black nationalist racist blm supporter
murdered a number of people by driving
over them with his suv in wisconsin
that was mass murder don't hear that
story much
episodes like that focus some attention
on who exactly is donating to blm and
who the organization recruits and is run
by the washington examiner looked into
this and it turns out that for several
months now nobody appears to have been
in charge of blm or the tens and tens
and tens of millions of dollars it has
raised huh
what's happened to all the money that
google sent that jeff bezos well the
address that blm lists on his tax forms
is wrong
and the charities two board members
won't say who control the at least 60
million dollars they've got in the bank
now